an old fishing net as trapped a Russian
mini submarine deep in the North Pacific
captain leftenant Slava Miller chef ski
knows the chances of rescue a small but
he's determined to try and save his men
disney company well hope never dies
there is always some hope we thought the
worst possible scenario was possible but
we were ready for it the whole crew was
trained for it Miller chef ski checks
the supplies on board as seven emergency
oxygen generating canisters the water
was found by accident in a burrow we
didn't know if it was a drinkable there
was about three or four liters inside we
didn't know how long we would need to
stretch this all they have to eat as
biscuits
milla chef's key makes a chilling
calculation each oxygen generating
canister has the capacity to keep the
crew alive for around nine hours with
seven canisters on board that gives just
63 hours in total even if they do all
they can to conserve oxygen 80 hours is
probably all they can hope for yes three
maximum
milla chefs key orders his men to don
their thermal suits sure they'll turn
off all non-essential equipment
including the heating system to save
battery power to reduce oxygen
consumption they'll keep still breathe
slowly and talk as little as possible
lovely the most important thing was
disciplined what role Nina as the main
priority was not to panic but to think
about survival about our chances about
our situation